[Music]
it is 6 39
and time now for our morning cup of joe
with metro sheriff joe lombardo good
morning matt
say good morning metro sheriff good
morning sheriff it's nice to see you
good morning
hey we know it's a busy day for you so
thanks for making time for us uh we have
a lot to ask you about new year's eve
but we want to start with this really
quickly
metro recently made a number of arrests
involving internet sex
crimes what can you tell us about those
and what do you recommend so others
don't fall victim yeah there was a
significant amount of arrests
unfortunately um so our internet crimes
against children
task force who works in conjunction with
the fbi that's a
normal procedure for them or a normal
type of investigation for them
and the sad part behind it is so easy
for them to do you would hope it would
be a difficult
type of crying to perpetuate but it
isn't and that's what's unfortunate
so it's important for parents to be
aware of what their kids are doing on a
daily basis
specifically to the internet monitor
their phones their computers
talk to them and you know and if you're
an anonymous person and you become aware
of a situation like this you can
call the internet crimes against
children task force here at metro at
3421 is the extension 828-3421 or you
can call the
national center for missing and
exploited children
you can do that anonymously they receive
tips from all across the nation
usually from third party uh internet
providers
they provide those tips to them and you
know specifically during this pandemic
uh their their traffic or their number
of tips that they're receiving
is growing exponentially i think that's
probably people lock down and board
these uh predators you know they're
experts at what they do
and they know all the key words to
entice children
to get them into their fold and i think
it's important
i guess the the crux of this have your
parents
uh engaged in your life yeah and you
really worry about that too with all the
distance learning and kids being stuck
in front of the computer so
good stuff to remember all right sheriff
so new year's eve
it is tomorrow night going to be a lot
different of course what's metro
preparing for on the strip
well like the last time we spoke um not
much changed from that so i'm i'm
it's hard to anticipate what the crowd
is going to be so we're prepared like we
normally are
in previous years for an enormous crowd
if it's unfortunately a small crowd
we'll deal with it
accordingly we've got about 100 less
officers
out on deployed this year we actually
have more officers deployed in the
neighborhoods
this year because of the governor's
restrictions and people abide
hopefully abiding by those restrictions
there's been a lot of airbnb
traffic and we're we're concerned about
neighborhood parties
that are going to pop up so we're going
to have teams deployed to respond to
them similarly like what we do on july
4th with fireworks
the curfew will be in place this uh on
new year's eve 6 p.m to 6 a.m
and we're going to shut down the street
around 8 p.m
for people to go out into the roadway if
they desire to do that
and then no fireworks unfortunately
so that that won't be a draw for people
because no fireworks
and then we'll have the restrictions
that we normally do during special
events like july 4th
and other events to include new year's
eve on what you can bring down into the
area in other words no baby strollers
no glass containers no big bags such as
backpacks
if you do bring those items we'll ask
you to leave the area with them
and don't return with them and then we
have to also deal with fremont street
i believe it's changing by the day
what this experience is going to be down
at the fremont street experience
whether it's going to be a charge model
for people to get in
uh whether it's going to be an open
model there will will not be any live
entertainment
but and covid being in where it is now
and how it's spreading now
that's going to be a major concern for
us so sheriff what are the ramifications
since officers are going to focus on
neighborhoods in particular
uh for illegal house parties airbnb and
also
for illegal fireworks um so yeah we have
the
fireworks statutes on the books um
if you are discharging illegal fireworks
we you
will confiscate them and we'll write you
a citation more than likely
and as far as the house parties or
neighborhood parties
we can close those downs because they're
illegal in the county
and you have to be permitted in the city
so
and then we have the covered
restrictions associated with it so
there's a lot of tools that the officers
have available for them
to address that issue and i anticipate
we're going to have to deal with it
this new year's eve because of people
not wanting to go to the strip
areas is metro taking any extra
precautions tomorrow night in light of
the bombing in nashville on christmas
day
yeah absolutely so um we're always aware
of our critical infrastructure
throughout the valley and we have um
folks dedicated to that job on a daily
basis
but we're also going to do a force
multiplier with our patrol officers in
the specific area commands where
critical infrastructure is located
and we're going to be do monitoring
those areas on a continual basis
all right sheriff it has been a tough
year what are you looking forward to in
2021
yeah i can't say that enough right yeah
it's been a tough year you know dealing
with the covid we had
two deaths internally here on my
department the economy
associated with the covet and and the
layoffs associated with the covid and
and in the protests you know post george
floyd and you know my officer shay
michelanas and
in the situation that he was put in and
and we're still currently dealing with
and so there's a lot of things i've had
to deal with and what is our job our job
is to fight crime and
provide that blanket of safety for the
community and but um
that was a little bit of a bright spot
for us in 2020
we were able to keep violent crime down
over four percent
and uh property crime over 13 percent uh
through
2020. so i'm proud of that with a
diminished workforce so
going into 2021 i'm hoping this
vaccine's the panacea you know
turn our economy around be able to hire
more officers
and you know move forward instead of
backwards
absolutely well we wish your officers uh
safety tomorrow night as they protect us
thank you so much sheriff for joining us
and happy new year we'll see you next
year
happy new year alex thank you if you
have a question for sheriff joe lombardo
send it to us on our website it's
8newsnow.com and you can find out if
your question was answered every
wednesday